[Music]
on today's show we're going to talk to a
couple of people who are struggling with
boundaries
and people they love how do you help
someone when the help they need
exceeds your abilities and we're going
to talk to a young mom
who's got three young kids who resents
the fact that her military husband has
moved her all over the place
she just wants stability stay tuned
[Music]
heyo i'm john and this is the dr john
delaney show
a live show taking your calls about your
life
we're all trying to figure out what to
do next
taking crooked wobbly steps
through life through our marriages
through parenting through all of it
by the way speaking of parenting you
know sometimes your kids do something
that's so good
and you're so proud of them the first
thing that comes to mind is straight a's
right or helping you know an elderly
person or
whatever the thing is helping your
husband or wife without
being asked whatever well i had a proud
moment
i always want my kids to find comedy
everywhere i do i want them to find that
and my wife was reading my daughter
she's gonna be five soon reading her
story the other night
and i'm walking by her room and
she's laughing my daughter's laughing
and she's laughing
in the kid laugh way where it comes from
inside your soul
it's the greatest sound on earth the
laughter of a child
but not just the laughter of a child but
it's it's when it comes from their
their chromosomes from their dna it is
coming from inside without they're
laughing
hard from their guts and i stopped and
stuck my head in and said
josephine was so funny and in between
gasps for of air she said
daddy in this story she's reading a
princess story my wife is reading it to
her
they said duke
duty and dude
duke duty and dude
somewhere along the way a duke of
something think the duke of earl
had a duty d-u-t-y
to protect the princess dude
and my little five-year-old daughter
heard
diarrhea joke diarrhea joke diarrhea
joke
somehow she equated duty d-u-t-y with
d-o-o-d-i-e she equated
um duke d-u-k-e with
d-o-o-k i guess is how you spell it i
don't know how to spell
duke but anyway my daughter's listening
to this princess story and what she's
getting
is some great diarrhea humor and listen
it's probably not the best thing that my
kids can already pick that up
but i was proud of her and i was excited
for because
in between this probably patriarchal
story she found some diarrhea humor and
listen everybody i'm proud of her for it
so as the duke of my show i've got a
duty to tell you when things are funny
and that was funny
all right so anything and everything on
this show we'll talk about it even if
your kids are finding bathroom humor in
classic fairy tales
and listen i'm working hard to put some
joy out into the world we're all dealing
with
hard hard things i'm not an exception to
that rule
every day i'm working on my marriage
every day i'm working on trying to be a
better parent
every day i'm trying to be figure out
how to be a good son-in-law be a good
kid
be a good neighbor i'm here with you
we're figuring this out together
and so when we can i'm gonna inject some
joy and some
laughter and optimism into the world i
got this awesome email from meredith
boggs
meredith boggs here's what she writes
john my husband is obsessed with your
show to put it mildly
excellent meredith you're already my
favorite email of the day so far
his growth over the past few years has
made him unrecognizable in the best ways
and so much of that growth is
continually propelled by the content of
your show
thank you so much all right so here's
what she writes
she goes on to write let me say it that
way i met my husband justin at middle
school church camp we began dating at 16
years old that's what i'm talking about
i knew those relationships would pay off
someday mine never did
but boy i went head over heels at church
camp relationships it's no exaggeration
to say we grew up together
we got married and shortly after we
moved abroad using our skill set to work
for a non-profit organization that
provided medical and surgical care for
special needs kids in china
after returning home to the u.s my
husband grew
was grew increasingly restless with his
job in health care and we sense there
was something more
he's the most intensely add person i've
ever met he tasted
tested in the 99th percentile in college
which explains so much of our four years
of dating
he's also a beautiful visionary and
he made a mid-career mid-20s career
change diving headlong into the wild
world of entrepreneurship and we
struggled hard for a season
his add became an excuse for his
behavior
which i responded to by taking on the
role as the adult and his mother which
is so detrimental
his anxiety peaked with the stresses of
a startup creating a wide gap of
disconnection
that i potentiated by my lack of grace
and understanding
i took the back seat to his new business
and nearly nagged him to death because
of it
can we just stop here meredith
your self-awareness is extraordinary
your ability to understand
yeah your husband's got some challenges
and you are bringing
gasoline to that fire thank you for
being a self-aware person it's awesome
fast forward five years of therapy and
spiritual guidance from mentors lots of
tears
and the hard work of rebuilding and i
don't even recognize the man i was once
married
to he's still that 80d boy and the
beautiful visionary he's always been
dreaming up crazy ideas every day but
he's grounded and committed
he picks up the phone each time i call
he apologizes quickly
there's no question in my mind what's
more important me not his business
our marriage not work he is wise and
contemplative
grounded and intentional continually
leading and loving me
wow justin boggs husband of meredith
my brother thank you for being an
example to everybody out there
struggling with add
struggling with whatever
set of genetics what set of behavioral
experiences whatever set of models their
parents gave them their neighborhood
their community gave them
whatever it doesn't matter because every
day we got to get up and go
that way we got to put down the pass
quit dragging that stuff with us
all through our life leaving a trail of
nonsense and
broken branches through us and we just
gotta go forward
you did that and my guess meredith
is that you also played a role in his
healing
and his coming around and your marriage
coming back together
when he started working on being present
being plugged in doing the things
that he needed to do so that add wasn't
an excuse for being a disconnected
husband and you quit nagging
because nagging is poison complaining is
poison it
never solves anything and you put that
down and decided to connect too
and those things work together and now
you guys got a rock-solid relationship
made of rubber bands right because it's
going to stretch and grow and stretch
and grow but good for you
way to go thank you for injecting some
joy into our lives
and some optimism and some hope into our
world it's a messy time and we need it
whatever is going on in your world give
me a call at 1-844-6900
good stuff rough stuff tough challenges
all of it 844-693-3291 or go to
johndaloni.com
show you can fill out the form and we
will check it out and see if we can
make it work to have you on the show all
right let's go out to
mary in miami florida mary how's it
going
and what can i do to help hi thank you
for taking my call i really appreciate
your time
um we my husband and i are
married we have two adult children um
our kids
let's call them their 21 and 23 are part
of young adults group
at our church and we have a young woman
that um
has joined the church group i don't know
eight ten months ago
and has become uh pretty involved in our
lives
um we've always opened our home for
young people
and just to give them a safe place to
hang out we love spending time with them
but this is the most challenging young
person i've
well person in general i've ever met
um and my question for you is
how do we love her without being
manipulated and without
having her absolutely can consume us
because i went from opening my arms and
my home to when i see her name
come up on my phone i just dread it in
the past 10 minutes she's already called
me two times this morning
[Music]
so what are things she's doing that's
weighing on you in this in in heavy ways
making you want to be the person that
you are not making you want to be a
closed door person instead of an open
door person
um because i feel like
i'm naturally i guess my gifting is to
shepherd people i come alongside and
listen and pray with and encourage
and i feel like that that's being taken
advantage of
she's an extreme person
she's mentally unstable she has
pretty much everything under the sun
including bipolar
anxiety she takes on every possible
addiction that there is it's almost like
she
goes and search for them from cutting
her body
she just recently diced herself up i
mean it was horrific
she is now baker acted for the fourth
time
she's only 19 years old she has
confessed of being
pregnant and falling out of a tree and
getting in car accidents
i mean the the list is endless and it's
all consuming so she'll send group
messages
to these young adult groups and and have
these extremes like
i ca i have to cut i don't deserve to
live i don't want to be here anymore
sure hey guys i think i'm pregnant hey i
think i fell off
uh you know i cut my leg on something
today i mean it's five extreme things in
one week at one point
sure so it's just too much
sure so there's a couple of things here
some of what i'm going to tell you
hopefully will be helpful some of it
you're not going to like me what i'm
going to say
okay is that cool fair all right yeah so
thing number one is you are recognizing
that you're over your head
and yes there is a a when people get
exhausting people that we care about
people that we've opened up our home to
get exhausting in this way
it's easy to and dangerous but it's easy
to begin to moralize it
that she is doing this for attention
she's doing this on purpose
and what i'm going to tell you is i want
you to reframe it and say
she's doing this because she's not well
and that's a totally different
perspective
the analogy i give to folks in this
situation is this
if my 10 year old son comes
out of his bedroom comes into my bedroom
and he says daddy i don't feel good and
he barfs
all over my bed at three in the morning
oh my gosh it's disgusting it's annoying
it's
gross and it's frustrating i'm not gonna
sleep the rest of the night i'm gonna
have to strip all the sheets off the bed
we're gonna turn all the lights on
everything
but i can't get angry with him because
he did the only thing he knew to do
which is to go to a safe place and say
daddy i'm not well and then the next
thing that happened when he wasn't well
is he barfed all over me
so i can be grossed out and frustrated
but
he came to where i invited him
and so what i want you to do is to to
not
look at her at this young woman as
someone who is trying to manipulate you
someone who is
um you know trying to hurt you guys but
you got someone who's not well
and is desperately trying to connect
definitely trying desperately trying to
matter
desperately trying to lean into people
in the only language she knows how and
you guys are over your head
right this is somebody who's not well
in a way that you all can't handle it
and she's going to go too far
cutting or she's practicing and building
up towards something or she's just
cutting
and it's not that big of a deal but it
freaks everybody out and it gets
everybody's attention
and and and so she needs professional
help and
she needs desperately a group of adults
to sit down with her and say we
love you and we want you here you can't
talk to us like that
because we don't have the skills to help
you in the right way
and so she doesn't get to blow up your
phone
and she doesn't get to blow up your
whatever
your time with graphic tales with
fall down tales with things that she
knows y'all can't handle
but you all have to be honest and open
and explicit with her and
she's got to have people that she can
call whether that's the doctor whether
that's her
psychiatrist whether that's her rehab
center whatever that happens to be
the second part of this is the part
you're not going to like
and it's this idea that
you feel called you feel your gift is
shepherding people walking alongside
them
being a hospitable place we love having
kids over we like
giving them a safe place the reality is
you like being that person for them you
like having
the laughter and the fun and the tears
you like being the go-to person having
people over your house
that's awesome your two kids probably
we're
super fortunate to have you all as
parents
but shepherding really happens when
things get hard and inconvenient
and the messy part of being a mentor is
2 am calls and the messy part of being
the open door
house is sometimes people come in that
open door oh man they're a lot
and so i would if you're going to be the
person who opens your door if you're
going to be the person who is there for
folks
don't just do it when it's convenient or
when it's not annoying or when it's
folks who are mostly have everything
together they just broke up with their
boyfriend and they need a place to go
unless that's what it is
but call it what it is right because my
guess is this woman
came and she had some struggles and man
initially
it was this person's got a lot i'm going
to be there for him
and then you found out in short order
your whole group did
whoa this is a lot the sexiness the
shine of this wore
off real fast and you realize working
with somebody with bipolar or
borderline personality disorder or
suicidality or cutting those around the
clock
frustrating exhausting times and if your
mentorship and hospitality runs out just
because it gets hard i mean that sends a
really tough message to everyone around
you and so
i want to honor you guys by saying yeah
you're way over your heads
you need to call somebody that can that
can be directly involved and you need to
let her know here are our boundaries
she doesn't get to drop these things on
you but she needs to know we can't
handle these things
and we don't know what to do with them
and so at that point
she's she's exceeding your boundaries
right and if it gets to it then tell her
we're asking you to not call us anymore
because you are only calling us to
drop things on us that we can't deal
with we don't know how to handle
if you are ready to say we don't want
you in our home
if you are ready to say we don't want
you around
that's a tough tough situation
because then you're gonna have to look
at your mentorship your calling and say
it's got limits to it
and it's only when it's easy right
when i say that does that hit you hard
does that
hit you in a way that makes you
uncomfortable makes you mad at me tell
me what's going on in your heart and
head
um no i hear you i receive what you're
saying i've i've
already yeah i've processed that um
there's selfishness
on my end you know when you get in tough
situations or you're
stretched you know the ugly comes out
sometimes and
reveals what you're dealing with so i'm
very self-aware of that
but we've gone from one end of the
spectrum to the other
and i just don't know how to manage the
in between because
when we started out i mean this was
months ago um
it was definitely an open door but when
you feel like
you're being taken advantage of it
almost feels like an abusive situation
and even my husband he's like honey this
just feels like you're being
abused at this point and we're all
exasperated the young adults in the
group stop responding to her they're
like we can't do this
every single day right so it wasn't for
like i want to be the person and i'm
going to save you but yeah there's
definitely reward when you can encourage
someone and
enjoy their company and you can help
them feel like a better person
obviously but i'm not equipped for this
i've told her many times we've gone from
the gentleness
the encouragement the ideas of how to
cope
we invited her for thanksgiving because
she lived on her own
um you know she's here in our home but
then you know she's
she takes her bandage off of her
diced up arm and she's like i hope you
don't care
it's really hot and she's got a you know
this sleeve on to cover it
and then she wears short sleeves and she
talks about it constantly
gosh do you think everybody you know is
bothered by this and i don't mean to
sound
insensitive but i'm kind of at that
point now because we've been doing this
for so long
sure she has a psychiatrist she goes to
celebrate recovery
she has a regular counselor she has a
trauma counselor uh coach
who i mean she's seeing three people at
a time plus cr
there's not lack of going to help she's
on medication
um and i've become like this close
person to her
but i don't text or message or call or
talk to you even my husband
and we're close right right so contact
anybody as much as this person and i
have said
hey girl i can't i can't message you all
day
i gotta get back to work right you know
those kinds of things and so a great
gift you can give her because
that's that's good for me to hear that
she's got all sorts of
other people helping her a great gift
you can teach her
now is what boundaries look like what
loving boundaries look like
and so it's going to be explicit saying
if you come to me and show me wounds on
your arm i am calling your psychiatrist
kick and scream fight and get mad i
don't care i'm not equipped to handle
that and i will call your psychiatrist
and it is totally inappropriate for you
to take your bandages off at a family
dinner that i invited you to
you are not welcome to do that in my
home i love you
and i love having you around you cannot
do that
and by holding her accountable by
telling her that i love you and i'm not
pushing away but that's unacceptable
you're going to show her and model for
her boundaries that she's never ever had
you're going to have to be prepared
prepared for the what if what if she
keeps doing it
are you ready to say you are not welcome
here
are you ready to tell her i will only
text you twice a day
you can text me all you want but i'm
going to turn the notification part off
on your text i'll check them when i get
around to
it so be it but i'm not going to let you
run my
world like that teach her what
boundaries look like and it sounds like
you're going to have to learn what
boundaries look like too
so it may be about you getting with your
husband and saying here's going to be
our boundaries i'm going to text her
once a day
once every other day we've gotten this
world where that ding
controls us no man we control that phone
i'll respond to you when i'm able to
respond
right and set up those boundaries
make sure that when you are a person of
hospitality and this isn't just to you
mary this is to anybody if you are a
person of hospitality
an open door person
make sure that applies to everybody who
walks in that door
that doesn't mean you have to accept
blood on your floor
that doesn't mean you have to continue
to get vomited on
but if you have an open door you've got
an open door
and people who don't look like you who
have different experiences than you
who are desperately trying to connect
with you may just walk right in
right and that's hard that's messy
and you've got to have good boundaries
and you've got to have professionals
you're lucky on this one because she's
got so many professional resources that
she can lean on
and now it's just a matter of setting up
those boundaries but thank you so much
for calling mary that's
a tough one this is tough when you love
people but they
exceed your ability to love them and
when they call your bluff
right everybody's welcome everyone can
come into my open door
except for you right and that's hard i'm
glad you're wrestling with that because
that's hard
all of us who are people of hospitality
wrestle with that
schools wrestle with that the government
wrestles with that churches
are always wrestling with that who's
welcome at your table
who's welcome there i love that question
it's hard and messy all right let's go
to bj and appleton
bj what's up my man oh my my man
sorry bj that's all right thanks for uh
taking my call i certainly appreciate it
no thanks so much hey what is what does
the bj stand for
bobby joe ah beautiful beautiful
beautiful bobby joe
all right so what is up how can i help i
have a son who
has a drug addiction um i've been
struggling with it for as far as i know
six to seven years his father died
unexpectedly when he was 16. i hate that
right after i he turned 16 and
things started to go backwards after
that
and i'm to a point where this
this roller coaster he's put everyone on
with his addiction
i'm tired i'm exhausted how old are you
bj uh fifth size 55
and how old is he now 27 27
is he married does he have little ones
he has two kids
two kids are they in a safe place
yes yeah do they live with him with
their mom
with their mom okay
so your sons had loss after loss after
loss huh
yeah yeah and you've had
loss after loss after loss huh yeah
yeah so can i tell you this bj you're
glad
you're allowed to be exhausted
thank you you're allowed to be super
frustrated and heartbroken
and pissed off and sad and heartbroken
again and again and again
what are some things you've tried to
connect with your son
i'm just just for the people listening
to this what are some things you've gone
through to try to connect with him
um he's been through group sessions and
counseling and rehab
then i've been there with him you know
i've attended his rehabs i've attended
his group sessions
you know i visited him when he was in
jail
always always let him know i love him
and support him and i'm there for him
and he so he has the tools from
uh previous group sessions and and
counseling sessions
he knows what to do he just won't do it
um
and i've told him several times i think
if he saw a therapist
and talked about the demons
that haunt him it would do a great deal
for him
but he just he doesn't do it do you see
somebody
i do is that helpful
it is very much so you're at a place now
where
no parent wants to be and i'm just gonna
be honest with you
and tell you the truth okay there's
absolutely nothing you can do for your
son other than continue to love him
and to draw firm boundaries that keep
you safe and you well and you whole
he's you can't make him see a counselor
and i know you know these things and i'm
telling you
i'm saying these things out loud for the
listeners as much for you but
until he decides he wants to get well
and whole he's not going to get well in
hole
and anything in between that is
performance right it's and it's going to
fall down
and it's real frustrating that he won't
get clean for his kids
it's real frustrating that he won't get
clean for his ex it's real frustrating
he won't get clean for you
but he won't i know i know he's an adult
he's an adult i can't
make him do anything but it's still that
mama bear mentality that wants to
love him and protect him and help him in
any way i can and it's frustrating
to just stand and watch it is the
the best way you can love him right now
is to take care of yourself
and that means sitting down with your
therapist and say i'm ready to draw
hard hard boundaries i'm ready to
create a life reverse engineer a life of
where i want to go
where i want to be not just constantly
in response to my son
and his addiction his challenges
and you build that world back
and that may not include him very much
who knows when he's going gonna decide
to turn it around he's had a supportive
mom
my guess is even before your husband
passed away there's probably some demons
way back there that he's
experienced that he's working through
but man that's tough loving an addict
i can't think of no other thing because
it's like having a funeral to someone
who's still walking around
and for you this is loss on top of a
loss you lost your husband
you lost your partner in crime you lost
your marriage
and now you're watching a ghost of your
son walk around and it's heartbreaking
and i wish i had better news for you
other than you've got permission to be
exhausted you've got permission to
at 55 build that life
and you can it's not too late and you're
not going to not have a hole in your
heart
and you're not going to not hurt
desperately
but you can begin to work towards the
places you want to go
the person you want to continue to
become the grandmother of those two baby
girls that you want to become
you can work towards that and hope upon
hope and pray upon prayer
that he falls down on his face and
decides i'm ready
i'm ready to go see somebody i'm ready
to do the hard trauma work
and work through this stuff because i'm
worth it my kids are worth it my mom is
worth it
my future's worth it but love comes with
risk and hits hard
i hate that for you bobby joe i hate it
for you
ugh i can't i can't i can't think of
anything worse i mean i'm wrapping my
head around i guess
the death of a child is is the worst
thing a parent can ever experience
but close to that is an addicted child
and if you're listening to this and
you've got an addiction problems
if you've got a mom or dad who didn't
treat you right if you've got a mom and
dad who did treat you right
hear me say you are worth getting well
man
you're worth not having to use you're
worth not having to eat you're worth not
having to
fill in the blank for your addiction
and it's gonna be hard to get there
but it's worth the the journey
it's worth those hard conversations it's
worth those hard counseling sessions
it's worth
painfully changing your behaviors and
falling down and scraping your knees and
your face
and hurting relationships and getting
back up and getting back up and getting
back up but it's worth it
it's worth it it's worth it and i hope
you heard the exhaustion in bj's voice
hope you heard the she's tried and she's
tried and she's tried
but doing it for somebody else isn't
gonna work you gotta do it for yourself
and you gotta know that you're worth it
we have a culture that is so addicted to
everything
so you're worth being well you're worth
being well thank you so much for that
call
thank you so much for that call bj all
right let's go to one more let's go to
allison
in new orleans allison how are we doing
this morning
good how are you good good good how can
i help
um so i'm really battling myself
right now with um a regretful decision
a big decision that my husband and i
have made
um he retired from the military a year
ago
and um we had planned on always
settling back home near my family i'm
the only child
i'm very close with my mom she's my best
friend
and um he had a job lined up and
everything
well he ended up getting a better job
offer
in a state we used to live in we were
stationed there before
and we jumped the gun and decided
financially
we're going to do it um and we moved to
this other state
that job fell through i did not get it
and now he's doing the job now he's a
police officer he's doing the job now
that he had lined up
back home near my family um
in virginia and i just feel like the
past
year i just i don't know what's wrong
with me like i just can't move beyond
this
and it's been it's been hard
so did does he not want to move anymore
um
this new police department he works for
yeah he does and i'm very grateful
for this department you know with
everything going on we are very lucky to
be where we are right now
um the community shows nothing but love
towards them he
is flourishing and i love watching that
for him it's been his dream job
um but we do have three children
and i am the only one not his fault but
i'm the one that has to take our kids to
their games
in their school events and you know i
don't have support with my family it's
just mom
still after you know a whole military
career and
i struggle with it every every time so
have you
not in a moment of frustration not in a
moment of rage or anger or
exhaustion have you sat down and talked
to him about it
i have and he would move in a heartbeat
okay um so why
why don't you move um
i think it's my kids i always said i
wanted to settle be settled
when my oldest started middle school
okay he started middle school the year
we moved here so he's now in seventh
grade we've got a fifth grader and we've
got a second grader
and i just want stability for them i am
tired of moving
i know but listen you're not stable
a mom who lives a life of
regret and who lives a life of
constant frustration i'm telling you
those kids are absorbing that
and you've heard me say this and i'm
going to say it a thousand more times
before
dave ramsey fires me someday you
those kids feel that on you and they
backfill that
gap between you and them with it must be
their fault
and they will spend every waking moment
trying to make sure that the
relationship with mommy's okay
and they're not going to do it on
purpose and you're not doing it on
purpose
but if you've got a situation where your
husband is ready to pack up and go
you were you were blessed in this season
you had man it's been a gnarly year for
police officers
good and bad and he had a supportive
group that trained him and taught him
and rallied around him in a community
that supported him
what a gift and you've got three healthy
kids
be bopping along you're exhausted from
moving
i've got all that but they need a
settled mom
they need a settled mom and they need a
mom that feels good
here's the thing you need to make sure
that your picture of what virginia's
gonna look like is real and it's not a
fantasy
well that's the problem that when you
get there right that
everyone's just gonna run it's gonna be
like the old days and you're they're
gonna dote on you and be there to pick
up your kids and go to the games with
you
it may not happen like that
and it may be that you're avoiding
creating friendships wherever you are
and it's hard for a military spouse
right that's i mean you've you've lived
a nomad's life that's really tough
but at some point when you decide i'm
gonna be settled you're gonna have to
plug
in and make new friends make new
community
be vulnerable with people that you don't
know and
continue to lean into that
and if your family does that for you
virginia awesome i
i i just talk to so many people who it's
just going to be that way once they can
just get wherever
they are going to go and the worst part
about moving is that you're going to go
with you
right and if you're a person who's not
settled who hasn't been settled who's
got regret in her heart because her
husband's moved her around the u.s
government's moved her around
that's not just gonna go away when you
land in virginia
no and i mean my husband says he'll know
but he does not like virginia
right so i think that's part of my
holdback too um
great great but he's really going to
love a wife who doesn't feel like a
martyr
and he's really going to love a
connected family
and at some point somebody's got to give
and if you are if you are
living less than if you are
living a life of regret
of just i tell you what man
i can want to live in a lot of places
but the place i want to live is where my
wife feels like her best self
right now your best self in many ways is
a choice
you've got to decide to be fully you
wherever you are
admittedly that could be easier with
family and connection and all those
things
right so if you've got a guy that's
willing to go
and you want to make one more last move
make one more last move
you deserve that he deserves that your
kids deserve that
but it's not going to solve everything
and when you get there you're going to
have to decide
i am plugging in and i'm growing roots
and i'm going to have to do the work
to not be a bitter wife
not be a frustrated person what's
past is past we did move our kids around
a lot i've moved around a lot i lost 10
years or however many years of
relationships of connections of whatever
whatever whatever partners in a pear
tree
we're moving forward
so i'm going to invite people to come to
games with us i'm going to invite
people to have meals over at our house
especially my husband's at work in the
late shift
i'm going to invite family members over
i'm going to go see a counselor so i can
learn new skills on how to
to plant deep roots i'm going to be
plugged in
because it may be allison that a move is
going to really be great for you
it was for my family it was really
important it was good
and when we got here we still had to
realize that we came with us and we said
a ton of work to do my wife and i
on reconnecting and re-learning how to
be married again
and really that's happened every time we
move to new cities
good for your husband for loving where
he's at but being willing to pack up and
move good for him
i say y'all start looking at real estate
in virginia and he needs to get his
application in asap and you'll need to
go for it
when you decide to move when you finally
move and land there
probably six months right i want you to
call me back and let me know how you're
doing
call me and let me know how your
family's doing
call me and let me know how your
marriage is doing but i want you to go
let yourself off the hook don't be the
martyr just go
awesome good for you i'm excited for you
all right
as we wrap up this show
i'm gonna pull in one of the greatest
songs of all time from the 1991
album not one two three four five or six
or seven or eight or nine
but the 1991 album 10
by one of the greatest bands of all time
pearl jam
and their classic song alive eddie
vetter sings
son she said have i got a little story
for you
what you thought was your daddy was
nothing but a
while you were sitting home alone at age
13 your real daddy was dying
sorry you didn't get to see him but i'm
glad we talked
oh i'm still alive
while she walked slowly across a young
man's room she said i'm ready for you
why i can't remember anything to this
very day except the
look that look uh you know where
now i can't see i just stare
something wrong she said of course there
is you're still alive she said
do i deserve to be is that the question
and if so who answers
who answers that question pearl jam
eddie better this is the dr john dolone
[Music]
show